so Hank a couple days ago I had a fairly
important phone call like important
enough that I can't tell you
specifically who I was talking to and I
was pretty nervous about it because I
always get nervous about phone calls but
it was going pretty well and then when
it came time for the phone call to end
they were like alright we'll take care
talk to you soon and I said best wishes
best wishes
you know they hung up the phone and they
said did that guy just say goodbye to us
by saying best wishes
so just a memo to all the teenage
nerdfighters out there who are wondering
will my self-consciousness ever go away
yeah no it won't best wishes
Hank as you'll no doubt noticed puff
levels have gone down considerably when
I went to the barber I said can you just
take a little bit off the top I like it
to be pretty long and messy and she said
sure thing I took off my glasses like I
always do when I get a haircut 20
minutes later I put my glasses back on
and I was bald and she said and I'm
quoting her directly here is that short
enough no actually could you make it a
little bit shorter because when I said
just a little bit off the top I like it
long and messy what I meant was I'm
joining the Marines so Hank as you know
I was gonna try to do a question Tuesday
video today where I attempt to break the
world record for a number of questions
answered in four minutes but
unfortunately it's going to have to wait
until next Tuesday because I haven't
even finished going through all of the
questions because there were more than
2,000 questions so question Tuesday will
be next Tuesday in the meantime let's do
some housekeeping housekeeping item
number one if you live in or near
Spartanburg South Carolina you should
come see me speak about my books and
sign them on Friday Saturday Saturday
this Saturday I'll be signing in the
morning in the afternoon and speaking at
two o'clock at the Spartanburg Public
Library Jambo read Jambo read is a nice
pun it's like all the fun of a party but
with books housekeeping item number two
if you have inter near Depew New York
and I know a lot of nerdfighters do then
please attend the meeting on Tuesday
March 4th when they're going to talk
about whether to keep my book Looking
for Alaska in the curriculum it Depew
high school you can find out more in the
video info housekeeping item number
three the nerdfighter boarding book club
Hank this is off topic but I really like
saying blurbing blurbing is one of those
words that when you say it it sounds
like your voice is turning into a robot
voice or being barbing or
ringg blurbing barbing blurbing anyway
nerdfighters if you want to participate
in the blurbing and potentially win
fantastic prizes you need to write a
blurb about Maureen Johnson's book 13
little blue envelopes of 10 words or
less and post it as a blog post in your
profile at the Ning we'll read them all
I promise the deadline is Sunday at
midnight then we're going to go to bed
promptly at 12:01 get some sleep wake up
the next morning and start the next book
in the nerdfighter blurbing book club
slaughterhouse-five by Kurt Vonnegut
which I'm picking because it's really
good and I haven't read it for a long
time
plus it's published all over the world
so international nerdfighters can
participate too and finally housekeeping
item number 4 Hank it's no secret that I
really love two things the first is
nerdfighter babies and the second is
when a nerdfighter finds another
nerdfighter and they fall in nerdfighter
like I like nerdfighter like so much
partly because it makes me feel like you
know if it wasn't for us then there
might be less like in the world which is
a really good feeling and a nice
counterbalance to having people say I
don't want to listen to this freak I
want to see giraffes doing it Hank
there's been quite a lot of nerdfighter
blight going around lately thanks partly
to the Ning which allows you know
nerdfighters to meet other nerdfighters
and look at their interests and read
their blog posts and see their pictures
and everything but the particular reason
I mentioning it is that the vlog lovers
YouTube channel is back noted secret
siblings Abbey songs from a hat and todd
todd lee are a nerdfighter like yay
that's right Hank they're touching and
hugging and nothing else
Hank speaking of nuclear chain reactions
of Awesome I hope I see some
nerdfighters in Spartanburg South
Carolina on Saturday and I'll see you
later this week singing I'm very excited
but I'm not going to tell them what
you're singing about Hank I think
there's only one thing left to say best
wishes